One thing I do know about is feral pigs.
I've studied them pretty,
pretty closely.
Why?
Because I'm friends with a lot of people that are professional hunters and uh,
I wanted to know how the fuck they got so big.
Like there's a video of a,
there's a photo rather one they called Hogzilla.
That was from Georgia.
It's a fucking enormous pig,
but it looks,
look at that mother fucker.
King Kong hog from Russia makes Hogzilla look like a baby.
See,
I'm not buying that.
Does that guy look at the guy's head?
See that guy's head.
That guy is a mile away.
Where the fuck is that guy?
That guy could be on top of that thing and that look looks like a German
shepherd.
How much does it weigh?
We have no idea.
This is a photograph.
Hold on,
let me see that tusks again.
Let me see.
The tusks,
Eh,
it's a big pig,
but it doesn't have to be that big.
That could be a 300 400 pound big.
It doesn't even say did they?
It 1,179 pounds.
So these go scales.
What website is this?
I've got scales.
Website.
Website is,
it's wide open spaces.
Hmm.
That's a pretty reputable,
well not all shoulder first five,
five and a half feet at the shoulder of Jesus Christ.
I got to see his picture.
He brought 200 of these.
Not specifically that one,
but it was a Russian boar.
Hmm.
He brought in from Russia and they've ended up breeding with local feral pigs
and they got big.
Yeah.
Well here's the thing about bores and pigs and all that jazz.
It all comes from the same genus.
It's all from something called sue [inaudible].
Sue scruff is all pigs.
What's crazy about that is like when you see a domestic pig and they look all
cute and cuddly and pink and shit.
When they get loose and they go wandering through the woods,
they turn feral and their face changes.
Their face gets longer,
they grow tusks,
their hair gets thicker.
This one,
it says the shoulder height.
Is that how high the shoulders are off the ground?
Right at five and a half feet.
Triste that's so big.
That's all.
I'm three inches shorter or taller than that.
Five and a half feet.
That's insane.
That's this tall on me.
So me standing up.
Okay.
I'm five,
eight.
Look at this.
Watch this.
Here's the pigs.
Here's the pig shoulder,
right?
[inaudible]
that's on.
Or is it like right there?
Where's three inches?
Like right here?
That's fucking insane.
It's a pig that high.
That's insane.
That's an elk.
Hugs.
Hogzilla was a shoulder.
Had a three feet.
That's almost double three though.
Five and a half feet tall.
So big.
But if it was a thousand pounds,
that makes sense.
Cause uh,
a good elk is like 800 pounds.
A longhorn steers are so far behind it though.
[inaudible] bullshit hunters trick.
It's a hunter's trait.
That's what's drawn.
It's back here.
I don't see his hands.
Do you see his hands?
I don't see you say,
trust me.
Look at it.
Listen that guys in the next 706 area code,
that guy's hiding.
He's way behind that thing.
You're supposed to be right next to it.
If that is a deceptive photo.
When you take a photo like that,
that is you doing that on purpose,
what you're supposed to do.
He's supposed to put your gun or your rifle or your,
or you're a bow and arrow.
You lean it on the animal,
you stand next to it so that people that know how difficult it is and people
say,
oh,
your trophy a hundred now he trying to kill a smart,
mature animal because that's the one that's healthiest for the population.
That's the one you want to take out of the breeding cycle.
This is one that's already spread.
It's jeans and hunter's respect.
When someone shoots a mature older animal,
that's a for sure.
It looks good,
right?
Those are not that good to eat unless you really know what the fuck you're
doing.
Like you gotta be,
you gotta Slow Cook that motherfucker.
That one you want to do low,
you want to probably,
you know Brian,
that bitch,
get them in a big old Vada saltwater with brown sugar and garlic and just let
them soak for awhile.
This article is sort of Santa could be bullshit bullshit.
I'm telling you,
that guy's too far away.
You've got to listen to me.
Try to see a guy that's that far away.
What do you say to her Russian,
Bro.
He's,
that guy is near the bumper.
That's a fucking car.
I bet they're pigs.
Look at where his shoulders are.
They line up almost with the bumper that he does.
He looks tiny.
He's way behind that pig in relation to the size of the car.
Exactly.
It was like a third grader.
It doesn't make sense.
This guy is hiding.
He's hiding behind that pig.
If you wanted people to know the actual perspective you'd say on that.
If he had a rifle leaning up against that pig and the rifle look tiny,
you'd be like,
Holy Shit.
That's a giant pig.
That's,
yeah,
but there's nothing in that photo that represents an actual perspective.
You'd have to be standing right.
Look,
he's hiding.
He's,
he was old.
We can't even see bitch.
You could see that ain't a five and a half foot tall pig.
Well that pig six one laying down in this picture.
Yeah,
and picture these guys on his knees.
The only evidence they have dead one.
That means that the Werewolf we have in the,
in the lobby could be real to that world was a thousand pounds.
It's even bigger than this pig.
Yeah,
that's stupid.
That's what people do,
man.
People take pictures of animals.
They hide.
Well,
it's in the hunting world is called the grip and grin.
Take a photo like a hold a deer and you like push them way out.
People do that with fish too.
Like you caught a big bass.
You take that big bass,
you put it way in front of you.
It looks gigantic,
right?
If you take that big basket like,
Hey,
look at my big bass,
right?
That's a confident person.
Confident person's got that bass behind him.
I'm sure that mother fucker do.
You know?
Beg that is wrong.
Bigger,
wrong.
Keep guessing.
Doesn't matter if this guy's a liar.
The guy with holding it out in front of him,
he's showboating.
I'm not buying it.
That fucking pigs,
300 pounds.
That's a baby pig.
That's one the Whitney you Rogan or against it?